hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Supergirl episode 1 video I'll
explain what's going on with the season
all the new characters just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
100% improved from last season so far
now we have Superman so it's always
going to be a slam-dunk when you have
Superman in episodes I think the real
test for Supergirl will be when she's on
her own but they like to head that line
at the end of the episode where he's
like you know what I think I'll stick
around for a little while it's just
their way of telling you that he will be
in the next couple of episodes it's kind
of like a two-part premiere so the
second part you know with the
post-credits scene metallo
is just the follow-up to that so they
haven't revealed exactly how many
episodes he's going to be in this season
but he'll be around a lot and they did
say that that was always the plan even
if it had stayed on CBS like they're not
bringing him on just because they came
to the CW but they did have that pretty
sick CBS burn which is pretty nice you
know what I think this new place is a
lot better than the old place you
probably picked up on it but the whole
episode because it was introducing
Superman back to TV was this big love
letter for the Christopher Reeve 1978
Superman film so they borrowed a bunch
of lines of dialogue like statistically
speaking flying is still the safest way
to travel they had the helicopter crash
Clark Kent as I live and breathe and
then cat grant even had her own miss
Tessmacher miss teschmacher so number 10
was all the classic Superman references
they like a lot of the dialogue that
they had when he was on the phone with
Perry White was also very much in the
tone of that 1978 film so number 9 Tyler
hoechlin Superman so much more in the
tone of Christopher Reeves Superman than
in the Henry Cavill super heavy version
of Superman so I think week to week he's
just going to be a lot more fun to watch
and so it just remains to be seen what
they do with him while he's on the show
they've said a little bit about how
they're gonna use him he's going to be
like this shining example of what a hero
is but the whole point of the series
like this episode was Cara picking a
path obviously she's going to make some
choices that Superman doesn't totally
agree with so they're going to butt
heads so there's going to be some
tension between them there's tension
between him and Martian Manhunter so
I'll explain that so number 8 WTF
martian manhunter beef with Superman
explained so the way they explained it
is is that martian manhunter and
superman found a meteorite it was made
of kryptonite after he found out what it
was he coined the term kryptonite so
like Martian Manhunter
came up with the name kryptonite and
when he decided to keep it on hand as a
deterrent like a nuclear deterrent in
case any Kryptonians went off the rails
Superman got pissed so as long as you're
keeping weapons of mass destruction
inside your home I'm not going to hang
out with you kind of thing so after a
Martian Manhunter was like nobody's
going to get their hands on it don't
worry you know don't worry about it I
felt like that was just then a letting
you know oh well metallo very clearly
going to steal the Kryptonite and use it
to power himself so that was Operation
emerald emerald as in green green as in
kryptonite number seven also a bunch of
comic book name drops so you got
inter-gang court'll matys kasnia
kasnia was actually a place they used on
legends of tomorrow in season one it was
like a place that Vandal Savage took
over the court almighty's has shown up
on arrow it was a big place in the
Batman comics inter-gang is one of the
big criminal organizations of the DC
Universe so they're getting way more
comic book II and then he also has the
joke about super telepathy she's like oh
my god is that actually going to be one
of my powers that be amazing and the
funny thing is is that was actually one
of Superman's powers in the classic
comics if you haven't read a lot of the
really old Superman comics they get
pretty ridiculous I mean like really
over-the-top
Superman has had almost every single
power that you could possibly think of
so that's why during events like crisis
on Infinite Earths and like their big
universe altering rebooting events they
trim that up for number six meet Lena
Luthor so if you don't know who Lena
Luthor is she was basically Tess on
Smallville her full name was Lou Tessa
Lena Luthor the Supergirl version says
that she was adopted by Lex's father but
on Smallville I think they actually made
her the biological daughter of Lionel
Luthor so either way you kind of get
what they're doing with her character
like she tells Supergirl I'm trying to
make a name for myself outside of my
family you can respect that can't you
and she's like yeah I totally get that
because she's trying to make a name for
herself
outside of Superman like everybody sees
Superman but they don't see Supergirl so
she's trying to stand out from her
family while at the same time trying to
make the name great so it's just one of
the ways the show is telling you that
lena luthor won't be one of the big
villains of the season more like a
frenemy like they're not going to be
best friends or anything like that and
then number five we learned that Lex
Luthor inside cell blocks X is behind
John Corben trying to kill Leena Luthor
so they really want you to sympathize
with Leena Luthor like they want there
to be no mistaking that Lex Luthor is
still around still very much a villain
and there are much bigger threats but
number four Supergirl makes up her mind
and decides to become a reporter
pursuing justice washes cara in a way
that enables her to leave the building
like actually go on scene so that she
has an excuse to jet away and help
people like if you're a receptionist
you're stuck behind a desk it'd be
harder for her to break away to help
someone like you'd have to find an
excuse to not be there it's kind of like
spider-man being a photographer so Peter
Parker the photographer that takes
pictures of spider-man needs to go all
over the city to find spider-man but
secretly he's really just going all over
the city to help people number three
though actual real big thing they kind
of tease this is like a future plot that
they'll follow up on later Superman vows
to help find Cara and Alex's father who
is Dean Cain so just letting you know
that they have not dropped that
storyline they'll still be plenty of
opportunities for former Superman to pop
up with all kinds of Superman Easter
eggs so remains to be seen how they
decide to surface him on the show but I
think it'll have something to do with
Cadmus labs and being the Cadmus is the
big bat of the CEO number two WTF Cadmus
labs the big bads of season 2 the way
they're pitching them on the show is
kind of like an evil version of STAR
Labs so you have people like Cisco that
make really cool toys only they're evil
at Cadmus labs and they'll be using them
to hunt aliens in they haven't really
talked a lot about it but they did say a
few things that during season 2 earth is
kind of be like a waypoint for aliens so
we'll get a lot of intergalactic
visitors that will serve as plot points
for future episodes so if you're
wondering where new characters are
coming from they're going to be a lot of
people
from outerspace but number one WTF of
course first big person to come from
outer space is Mon L if you don't know
who he is in the comics he's basically
ad Aksumite who's like a Kryptonian
cousin who has similar powers but
slightly different weaknesses they
haven't really said how they're gonna
deal with that on the TV show if it's
going to be super true to the comics
because instead of kryptonite being his
weakness lead is his weakness so it's
really weird so they might just do away
with that and make him vulnerable to
kryptonite just like Cara and Superman
but the way they pitch his character
like they kind of explained in the
episode that he's from this special
place in outer space where time kind of
stands still so he's much older than
Cara and Superman like much much older
but he looks just as young so one of the
big reasons they said they decided to
use the character just in general on the
show is because they wanted to tell that
fish-out-of-water story like Cara's been
living on earth for a long time so she's
assimilated the culture she is fully an
American girl like she loves pizza
she loves like all this junk food Mon L
is going to be like that super
old-school dude who can't stand
Millennials like she'll try to help him
assimilate and they've said that it's
not going to go well so the other big
thing you know potential for night
crossover material is that the invasion
storyline that they're using for the
four night crossover involves the daksa
mites
who are on the side of the invaders so
while Mon L himself isn't going to be
like a huge villain on the show there
will be a lot of tension with his
character and I wouldn't be surprised if
they use the daksa mites in the big 4
night crossover just because the way
they were used in the comics but if you
haven't read that don't worry you don't
actually need to read the invasion
storyline it just reads a little bit
like New Krypton when all of a sudden
Earth is flooded with people from candor
so they could do like a version of New
Krypton only with like a new dak some
twists but remains to be seen it's just
all stuff from like way further in the
future so let me know in the comments
what was your guy's favorite thing from
the episode what do you think about all
the 1978 Christopher Reeve Superman
stuff I feel like they did a really good
job with that
so I really like the tone I like the
energy we'll see how it goes week to
week so I'll be doing videos for the
next
full of episodes but I feel like it's
just a hundred percent better than it
was last year so really hope they can
keep the momentum up but as promised
there will be a DC giveaway that'll just
run across all the DC videos I do during
the week the DC TV shows so all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's
just $20 Amazon gift card so I'll remind
everyone when I post my flash video
tomorrow night so we got flash tomorrow
night then a new episode of arrow and
then legends of tomorrow Justice Society
is premiering on Thursday so I'll remind
everyone about the schedule when I post
DC videos but if you have any special
requests for bonus videos or think you
know things from episodes that you guys
want me to do just let me know in the
comments well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my killer
frost trailer video and you can click
here for my flash episode 1 video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight